[Music]  oh  all right you're gonna throw them this  is us salt licorice uh candy licorice  and these are like greasy gummies  it's also quite uh  sentimental because this is like from my  from my childhood  it's a very it's very it's  salt licorice  is is very very popular  because we're  i'm curious to weird you try it you've  never tried salt licorice beforehand  there sir i'm very excited to see that  holy sh  sorry welcome  you people are crazy this is how we  treat ourselves that actually burned my  tongue  it tastes like a mouthful of sea water  it tastes like you'd made a mistake you  know what i mean when you fell into the  water  i can't believe you give that to  children